one of our local sponsors has decided to  do a big promotional tie-in with the  Fifty Shades of Grey movie check it out  after you see Fifty Shades of Grey  come on down to done right hardware for  our Fifty Shades of savings sales  spectacular we've got everything you  need for the bedroom like rope duct tape  caulking guns  clamps clothing pins toilets legs  fireplace tools rain ponchos so you  don't get semen all over yourself  door knob on the end of a power drill  use that for I don't need to tell you  jar lifters pitchforks plungers candles  and gear luminox the candle goes up the  butt  you did you know the buttocks while this  is tickling the genitals little over  back so yeah you heat up the buttocks  while you tickle the genitals and lower  back done right hardware where SN M  stands for savings and more savings  candle goes up to buy  [Applause]  you